[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it wasn't that long ago that our next
guest was known as a
world series winning manager he's got a
new title he's show a utani's manager
he's uh joe madden who joins us
on the show how's that feel is that it
official title joe
i'll take it it's it's been rather it's
been a lot of fun he's uh you saw him
during the
uh all-star weekend or a week two days
he's all of that he's just a wonderful
young man
he's very humble he came across
perfectly
and probably the best talent possibly
that's ever played the game
who would you compare him to you know
i've been asked that and
everybody goes all over the map and um
you know
obviously the the babe ruth comparisons
we never knew what the babe actually
looked or played like we just see the
uh those little legs running around the
bases a lot but i i would say
it's more like a bo jackson for me um
just to be able to dominate uh bo
dominated once both sports but
choi dominating both sides of the ball
in our game is so
different and i don't even it's going to
happen again i don't know to this level
but some kid's going to come along to
try to do and probably accomplish
even uh lorenzo in cincinnati that kid's
pretty good
and i've ever seen him he's out of cal
state fullerton he's pretty
he's pretty good hitter also but anyway
it's it's going to be a while but i'd
say beau
regarding the dominance like on both
sides of the ball and what a great
athlete that he actually is
when we were growing up chances are your
best player
your best hitter was the pitcher
right but at what point did we go okay
you can't do both
you can't be a pitcher and a hitter i
think uh of course you did it in
literally
i did it in tinder's league ball myself
i did it american legion ball
um when you get to college
i actually started out as a pitcher and
i i stopped pitching because i couldn't
hit anymore
so i became a catcher but i think by the
time you get to college they make you
make that choice i think up to that
point
a lot of guys are able to do both you
don't play as long as the season
uh the competition is different the
stresses on what you do in your body is
different
uh training all these different that's
the specialization that's necessary to
dominate as a pitcher
or as a hitter is different so i think
you could get away with it uh probably
through college at some point but the by
the time you get
to professional ball it really really uh
causes you to focus on one right or the
other except
if you have this kind of a talent like
show he does what
did you discuss with him about competing
in the home run derby the
guys we'll talk about you kind of screw
up your swing and and just the amount of
energy
that it takes to be in that yeah i did
and uh
here's the thing i you know we get we
put all these parameters on everybody
anymore
everybody tries to put it in somebody's
head um what you can and cannot do and i
don't do that i don't believe in that
i don't even know who came up with that
in the first place uh it's an easy
narrative
that's easy to defend in a sense and
that it's possible i'm not saying it's
not possible but
and i'm not going to deny the fact that
i like the i wanted him to win but i
wasn't
upset that he didn't it was out after
the first round uh but
all this stuff i think we uh in charge
these people in charge these days we
we attempt to get in the way of
greatness of a lot of athletes by
putting restrictor plates on all them i
don't like to do that
this guy is a great athlete he signed up
to do this he sent him to do both
so why would we restrict him from doing
both and on top of that he wants to
i mean there's times you have to push
players to do certain things or ask them
to do certain things shohei's wanted to
do this
from the beginning so never get in the
way of a player's greatness and stop
talking about getting hurt all the time
we put this in people's heads and all of
a sudden it becomes a self-fulfilled
prophecy
i just wonder about being too cautious
with today's athlete because
joe we grew up when you know guys
completed games bob gibson sandy kofax
juan marichelle
go down the list you you know that was
the the badge of courage i'm gonna
i want to complete a game uh you know i
look back on job at chamberlain i think
the yankees
over pampered him and i don't think he
ever could ever get out of a tough
situation because
whenever he got into one they take him
out so how do you have that
let me let you walk and fall on your own
all the above you're right um a part of
it has to do with money
and agents and all these different you
know you want to try to extend your
your shelf life to make more money over
a period of time i think that's part of
the narrative but then again
if that were the case why is everybody
still getting hurt
all these new different training methods
and diet which listen i'm all into all
of that stuff
we could go overboard with everything
diminishing return sits in with almost
everything we do in our life at a
certain point
and you go overboard you become an
extremist in all these different areas
and i'm not into it
i do love balance i think balance is
necessary you should have a
mcdonald's a big mac at some point and
of course you can eat properly
for the next week or 10 days balance
this whole thing out don't be an
extremist and i think that's what we've
become
with everything that we're doing we're
extreme and i think
there is a middle road i believe in the
gray area of everything
and when you experience both sides i
think you you turn out to be a better
human being actually i'm into liberal
arts i've been to the liberal arts
method of
teaching baseball and i think we become
polarized with all of this and i don't
think it's healthy
so i agree with you i think if given the
opportunity
um a lot of these players were talking
about pitchers would be able to pitch
more deeply into games and it needs
to start in the minor leagues and just
just to cut it off here but
when i was managing an 82 in salem
oregon
uh kirk mccoskill was one of my pitchers
and he pitched a nine inning complete
game
shutout giving up two hits no walks 12
strikeouts against the medford ace
wow that would never even occur today a
minor league manager would lose his job
if he even attempted to permit a pitcher
to do something like that
he's joe madden the angels manager
three-time baseball manager of the year
two-time world series champ
given uh steven a smith's comments on
shohei ohtani and the language barrier
um how much pressure does shohei feel
to be able to speak english because
i don't i don't think he feels pressure
i think he's learning you know it's like
if you're in a situation i speak some
spanish right and uh
on occasion the spanish reporters will
ask me to do something
in spanish it's a very unnerving
situation and
and you try and you concentrate and
focus you don't want to make a fool out
of yourself it becomes embarrassing
so when you're but if you're fluent in
that language obviously
it's much easier to do my point is as
shohei
learns more which he is and i believe he
communicates with us he says a lot of
different things in english but
if you put a microphone in front of
somebody until you become
pretty comfortable with that you don't
even want to go there because you don't
want to screw up you don't want to be
interpreted in the wrong way that's all
that is
because shohei does a great job with
this epays interpreter
who we also love is outstanding so give
them time
it's like anything else give them time
we're just in a different culture in a
different environment
you go to japan to learn the language
that quickly and speak it fluently
during an interview
not an easy thing to do i can't even
imagine that so give him time he's a
very bright young man
he's engaging he wants to learn and he
will i promise you he will
but it's just a it's a process man like
everything else
what was that meeting phone call like
when you had to tell albert pujols
that uh you were letting him go i didn't
i wasn't a part of that actually um
uh i spoke at albert that night before
that game um
he was upset that he wasn't in that
lineup and i couldn't tell him
everything
that was going on that i knew was going
on uh later on that night that was uh
john carpino and and perry um and asian
art gm they're they're the guys that
spoke to him about it
and um so since then i really haven't
spoken albert i know he was upset
leaving and uh i understand that
completely and i don't blame him
however it's worked out wonderfully for
him and wonderfully for us it was the
right thing to do for everybody involved
and sometimes it takes a little time for
people to realize
or understand that wish him i thought it
was great through that he was able to
stay in los angeles didn't have to pick
up and leave
family was not uprooted all those kind
of things that you
would that makes it difficult so it's a
win-win absolutely for everybody
involved and
uh we're going to see him again he's
going to play well against us i
absolutely believe that and i think it's
great i think it's great for baseball so
win-win uh the rule changes the
commissioner said we're going to take
away the uh
seven inning double headers and not
going to put a runner on second base
uh next season uh what do you what do
you think of those decisions
well first of all the runner at second
base has been a thorn the whole time i
uh
i'm not uh to expedite or a game
just for the sake of expedition i don't
understand that i don't get it
uh and this is one of those things our
game is is based under heath and
tradition
why do you want to subtract everybody
wants to take tradition out of
everything anymore either
it can't you just don't want a microwave
everybody wants to microwave everything
let the game be played yeah there's
going to be some really uncomfortable
nights that stink
when you have to stay there 17 innings
and lose possibly
horrible method horrible moment but
that's how this thing is done
so let's let's do that again and that's
part of what's happening
front offices are really freaked out
about this stuff because then you have
to use pictures
more than you would like to or you have
to shuttle guys between
um aaa back to the big leagues to uh
boasting yourself for the next day those
are the problems that's what the real
issue is here it's not about the game
itself
and as a kid i love dexter trainings
if the game was beginning to be played a
little bit more or longer
i would love that i'd understand her
school and i understand his work i get
all that stuff
but that's what the game is so a i'd
love to see that go away
the seven inning double header is
interesting um
i'm good with going back to nine but i
really would hope that they don't go
uh day night that's the part that really
is the kicker
i understand i understand the gate i
understand it's probably not going to go
away
but if you want to make it palatable to
all of us
uh play two nine any games that haven't
uh concurrent game over half hour later
it's game two that would be the the
better way it used to be when we were
right yeah
growing up yeah exactly yeah well that's
better for everybody
um you know when it when it comes to
what the game is now
and the strategy now can you see
somebody being
counter-intuitive uh you know like
whitey herzog's st louis cardinal team
could you could you build a team on
speed defense putting the ball in play
and and still be and having a good
pitching staff is somebody going to come
along and go
we can't compete with big markets and
getting sluggers
we're going to do this i think sluggers
are going to be part of it i still do i
don't think that's going to go away what
dwight he did there i mean that was
i mean i'm a big whitey guy why'd he
work for the angels for a bit and that's
where i got to know him i thought that
was
i thought he was brilliant um i i'd like
i've always said i'd like to have it all
why can't you have a couple sluggers you
know george hendrick was on that team my
buddy because
he was on those particular teams jackie
clark stepped in there they had some pop
uh but they're able to really listen
when you were
or you're preparing a game in the other
dugout you know that other team
could fly and they're going to put
pressure on you on defense all the time
that's an unsettling feeling that's
worse to me in the dugout than the team
that has two or three guys
that may take you deep i think you could
mitigate that a lot more easily than the
team that's constantly
putting pressure on you that bothers
everybody on the field i love that style
and i would like for the angels to be
that style and my my
theme for this year plays like play like
it's 1985 i got this cool little
shirt made up about it the point would
be uh to play the game
uh more completely as opposed to again
walk strikeout homer etc
so i think it could all be done i really
do and i think it comes down to drafting
we just went through the draft
i know we took pictures which is
absolutely necessary
but i've i even talked to theo i've seen
a couple years ago and they went to 40
rounds and i asked them
why wouldn't you take the rounds 30 to
40 just speed guys
just guys that could absolutely fly and
see if you could build them from there
and even if you hit on one a year
my goodness after four years you've got
four guys that can fly and it's kind of
tantamount to what the
kansas city royals baseball academy used
to be like in the 70s
which i still think was a brilliant idea
and that would be something cool to come
on back too but
you've got you have to draft and build
and nurture this kind of
pattern if that's what you want to see
and i'd love to see that
but you know what that pressure was like
when when ricky henderson would get on
first base
willie mcgee i mean it just it it
changed the atmosphere of a game it felt
like and and
i know you can have a bomb and somebody
can hit it 450 feet
there was something unnerving about
somebody on first base
that was that was that slow water
torture and it gets into the pitcher and
then the catcher and then the manager
everybody i i don't know i missed that
element there and i don't know if that
comes back
that you know the stolen base no you're
right 100 i'll tell you where it went
away it went away because of analytics
that's why it went away and that's
that's another part of the game we could
talk about for another hour
where i am an advocate but i'm telling
you analytics has really kind of
squashed the stolen base
because i'll just be quite frank with
you when when a guy would get thrown out
on the bases on a steel attempt
i promise you post game somebody from
the front office would come down and
talk to the manager about what happened
there
you know we don't want to make outs on
the bases and then the manager has to go
talk to the coach who then has to go
talk to the player
i mean and this is and so about that by
by the time that all gets done
these guys lose their aggressiveness
their assertiveness and you have to be
all of that in order to be a great base
stealer so
there's a lot of stuff that's that's
gone away based on a trickle down
from analytics from the front office
down to the field give me your favorite
minor league
managing lifestyle story
wow i'll tell you what i loved i love
the road i love to ride on a bus
weirdly and i drive one now we jay my
wife's right here with me right now
we have a 45-foot winnebago grant to our
grand tour rv i love the road you're in
the winnebago now
no we that's parked somewhere here we're
in actually in a hotel room oh okay
um we're here we're in here uh sin i got
my kids and my grandkids are here
but i'd say you know as amanda you sit
in the first seat right first seat
up in the front of the bus right on the
right side and as you asked that
question i could see myself
uh in the texas league now the texas
league i was in midland texas
uh in your division you'd have to go to
el paso like six and a half seven hours
or beaumont 11 hours or san antonio i
think was eight or sometimes
jackson mississippi or little rock
arkansas
that's 10 plus but i'd sit in that front
seat and at that time you had the
the little cassette player with the
fuzzy headphones you put on your head
and
you'd bring a pillow in a blanket you'd
wrap yourself up and i'd bring a book i
was
a racist reader and i loved it
you turned the ac way down and you
freeze in that front seat you
have to sleep and you wake up and you go
to some kind of truck stop in the middle
of the night grab some food and
get back on and i promise you i'll leave
i left yankee stadium a couple weeks ago
we won a pretty tough game like one or
two o'clock in the morning walking out
to the bus and i looked up and i said
thank you i'm still have that
opportunity to relive those moments that
i had
as a young manager coming up which if
you want to romanticize which i tend to
do that's it
and that's the part about the minor
leagues that i
i really did enjoy weirdly i was on some
in some leagues that had tremendously
long bus rides
but you didn't have a durham moment did
you
um i didn't i did him before
yeah when i was in boulder colorado i
would we did that before he did that
um what'd you do me stan jakubowski and
rod boxberger who's
the dad of brad boxburger were in charge
of the
colorado university baseball field where
the boulder collegiates played
and baldi musketti was the owner of that
team
and bali was the guy that got me my
break anyway
we were in charge of the fields i said
stanley he's not giving me any days off
i don't want to play i'm the catcher
and we're playing like i'm catching like
back to back to back double hitters
so i had enough i said we're going to
flood the field we did we went out that
day
and i the night before you put those
things on the
sprinklers we have to crank it a little
bit and then
and we left it on all night and you get
there the next day baldi shows up here
what's happened here
damn baldy i don't know the sprinklers
got stuck well we got a game tonight he
said i don't think we can get that
baldy brings in a helicopter you know
for foot to get all the water off the
field and then me and statue
and boxy had to go out there rake the
infield go buy some gasoline and burn it
so the infield's ready to by the end of
that i have to catch that night anyway
so we we went through the whole process
and i think that's that was 1975 so that
was
pre-bull durham man uh susan sarandon
wasn't waiting for you was she
no no no no she was not
to shaw as they said uh joe great to
catch up with you thanks for joining us
good luck the second half of the season
always a pleasure to be with you man
thank you bud that's uh joe madden
angel's manager shohei ohtani's manager
but also a three-time baseball manager
of the year and two-time world series
champ